Hi everyone. Today we will talk about
agents, building agents. So, how we are
leveraging coding assistance and spec
driven development to build reliable and
secure agents. First of all, just a
couple of notes about myself. I'm
Alfonso. I'm a tech lead at NearForm. We
are a services company.
I am currently working on some of our AI
agentic projects. I'm supporting
multiple teams adopting AI native
engineering and I'm also a O'Reilly
author of the book Learning AI Native
Software Engineering.
So,
we are seeing in the in the industry
that right now everyone wants AI agents
for workflow automation, search, you
know, every use case that you might have
in mind.
But, AI agents come with a sometimes a
very high cost.
They have hallucinations. They have an
entire new set of problems. Of course,
they are non-deterministic. So, today we
will see how we are building and
improving iteratively AI agents. And of
course, as you may guess,
how can we do that, right? AI is very
powerful and very good at building any
type of software.
And given that AI agents is just one
type of software, as you may guess, we
are using AI to build AI.
Um
As I was mentioning, there are a lot of
problems, a lot of different problem
classes with building AI agents. Uh
non-determinism is one of those,
latency, cost, hallucinations,
a lot of stuff really.
Uh but today we will see how to solve
them at least partially by leveraging
agents and the repeatable process that
we developed over time on our projects.
Just as a very very quick refresher, um
we can say that an AI agent is basically
just
an LLM, which is like the brain of the
agent. Then the LLM is connected to a
bunch of tools. It has access to a bunch
of context and basically lives into an
agentic loop. So, that's the that's the
gist of it. Of course, there is way more
into AI agents. There is everything
around observability. How do how do we
ensure that, you know, it's doing what's
what's necessary? So, everything around
evals that we will discuss in a minute.
But like
just from the first principles, we can
say that an agent is an LLM inside a an
agentic loop, which is connected to
tools and can retrieve context. That's
it.
Now, there are a couple of classes of
problems that we will analyze today. So,
the first one is bad performances on the
evals, and we will see what the evals
are in a minute. And the second one is
bad performances on live data,
which sometimes is similar to what we
have on the evals,
but you know, live data coming from real
users with, you know, real expectations
from the system can be a lot wider and
sometimes a lot messier as well.
So, let's analyze the first the first
failure mode. So, we have bad
performances on evals.
Before we analyze
this failure mode, I just want to
introduce you to go to the context of a
golden data set. Basically, a golden
data set is a file or a set of files
that we develop together with the
subject matter experts when we are
building our AI agents. And basically,
this file defines what is the input that
the system should retrieve
um, and should get sorry, and what is
the expected output that we should get.
Now, in the naive case, the expected
output, as we can see here on the right,
can just be like impossible, or like a
number, or a text, so it can be a lot of
things.
In real-world scenarios, the expected
output can be, for example, I do expect
the system to call this tool,
or call this tool with this parameter,
or
call this tool in this chain, right?
Because maybe I want to
do a retrieval and then do an update,
you know, so
how we define the output
is very different in every in every
agent. And the idea is that we want a
way, basically, to ensure that our agent
is working correctly. So, that's why
we're building the golden dataset. You
can see the golden dataset as a test
suite, but in a non-deterministic
scenario. So, when we build the golden
dataset, we also have to build a scorer,
or a set of scorers, that can basically,
go through the golden dataset together
with the LLM,
and then can give us, basically, a
number in the end, which is saying,
"What is the current accuracy of the of
the system?" So, that, you know, we have
a baseline, we can look for regressions,
and we can further improve the system
over time.
Now, let's let's assume that we have a
very simple hello world agent. In this
case, I'm using Mastra. It's a very very
simple agent, as we can see. I've called
it mad agent, but in reality, in the
golden dataset, we have
multiple types of questions, right?
But, let's assume that this is our very
simple agent, right? So, it doesn't aim,
it has just couple of instructions,
has has a model, of course. As you can
see, it doesn't have any tools yet.
So, it's like the the bare minimum.
Um we also built a naive evaluator. So,
if you remember from the golden data
set, we only have inputs and outputs.
And what this very naive evaluator is
doing is checking whether the um LLM
output contains the ground truth output
that we are expecting.
Of course, once we run the eval suite
here, the results are very poor. So, as
we can see, um we have a pass rate of
18%, right? Uh just because a
a lot of questions are simple enough,
like additions, multiplications, right?
Are simple enough so that the actual um
LLM has this knowledge in its training
data, and it doesn't need access to any
external context or like any particular
tool to answer these questions. So, 18%
of the questions can be answered by the
weights of the LLM, the rest can't. So,
we need a way to actually improve this
pass rate.
Some failure modes that we can expect
are well, first of all, the agent is
missing the right tools, right? So,
let's assume that I expect from my agent
to be able to surf the web, fetch web
pages. If I'm not giving those specific
tools to my agent, of course, every eval
that is expecting that, it's going to
fail miserably. So, first of all, we are
maybe just missing some tools, or uh we
don't have the right system prompt.
Because the system prompt basically
contains all the instructions, uh all
the behaviors that we should expect, and
that we shouldn't expect from our agent.
So, in a lot of cases, um a lot of the
optimizations will be just to tweak the
system prompt and update it so that um
you know, our agent has
all the information it needs to work on
our domain.
And then, um of course, context
retrieval, which is maybe our agent
doesn't know where to look for
information. Of course, usually context
retrieval is implemented as tools,
right?
Um maybe it's, I don't know, an accurate
search in our system. Maybe it's a fetch
on the web, you know, all these kind of
things. So, we need to give enough um
let's say tools uh to our agent so that
it can retrieve all the context it
needs, of course, in a secure way.
Now, the question is
can an AI agent improve another AI agent
autonomously or semi-autonomously?
And um
Karpathy, Andrej Karpathy, which is one
of the most well-known AI scientist on
the planet at the moment,
implemented something which is called
auto research.
Basically, auto research is a uh loop
which um updates the code, updates the
hyper parameters, updates the the actual
Python code of machine learning
algorithms.
And it actually shows that a coding
agent
tweaking the code of machine learning um
of a deep learning algorithm
can actually improve the results, right?
So, that's the um
that's that's the loss that we can see.
And basically, every uh dot here in this
chart is an example is a task
that the system is doing um by changing
some of the parameters. And we can see
that the baseline has a specific
accuracy. And while we go um while we go
with the number of experiments, accuracy
is improving. And therefore, of course,
the loss um
the the loss is decreasing.
Now, the question is, can we do the same
with AI agents and not just like machine
learning models?
The answer is yes. So, I built something
which is called AutoAgent,
which is
basically the same idea, but applied to
um
actually like AI agents, right? So,
basically this is a loop which is able
to
run the evals and then um
update the code of the system, try new
system prompts, create new tools, doing
everything autonomously, and then check
again whether things improved or not.
And it actually works quite well. So,
here we have a few iterations, and this
is the AI agent This is the naive AI
agent stat agent that we have seen
earlier.
And in that agent, as you can see here
on the bottom left, um
we have the baseline accuracy, which was
18%, and we managed to reach up to 83%
um in like something around 10 uh 10
iterations. Now, of course,
that's a um
that that's a very naive case, right?
Because we started with something which
didn't have any tools and nothing else.
So, it's relatively easy for the system
to improve this agent. But, uh we also
improved um some evals by 10% on a
production agent that was already
humanly optimized.
So, actually the the machine uh the
the agents the the coding agent found
new ways that humans didn't find um to
improve the agent, and we got plus 10%
on some of our internal benchmarks.
Now, how does it works? Actually, I I
gave already like a few insights of how
this works, but let's see it in details.
So, basically, the core idea is that we
have a coding agent, in this case Claude
Code, but it can work with multiple
coding agents.
It builds the agent, so it writes the
code of our target agent, and then the
target agent is giving feedback to our
Claude Code or whatever coding tool
we're using
as evals, right? So, it's giving some
information as okay, here I got some
regressions or these evals are not
passing.
Also, Claude Code can read the traces,
the thinking traces, or like the full
trace of the target agent to see whether
something broke or something is not
working as expected, so it can do like
self-improvement.
Of course, there is the human in the
loop,
and the human in the loop is usually in
structuring the initial agent and giving
as much context as we can to our coding
agent about what it can do with other
relevant files, what it cannot do, like
just to give an example, updating the
golden data sets or the scorers
just to let the evals pass is not a good
idea, so we want to enforce we want to
tell the
we want to tell the AI agent to not do
that, right? So, as humans, we can
we can steer a little bit our our coding
agent so that it can optimize the target
agent.
Now, there are a few steps, right? The
first step is to create an optimization
job. Of course, it's very easy,
everything is a markdown, we all love
markdown now, so we have we can define
the objective, we can define target
repository, the metrics,
and literally everything, right? So, in
this file, we can give as much context
as we want
to our coding agent so that it can
actually
run and improve the target agent.
And then the second step is to run the
loop. So basically, we run the evals
once, so we we we generate our baseline
data. So we understand what's working,
what's not working, you know, the system
will generate a first report. And then
we run the loop, the optimization loop.
So we can see that in the first case,
we get a regression, so basically the
system works by
creating an hypothesis. So it's tackling
one class of problems at a time.
It's updating the the agent and it's
running the evals again.
And then it's saying whether we got a
regression, an improvement, or something
else
happened and so the agent can decide
whether to roll back the change or move
on. So in this case, in the first
iteration, we got a regression, so we
want to roll back. Um then we see a 5%
improvement, which is great. So in this
case, we are getting
we're creating a new hypothesis, we get
a 0% improvement, unfortunately, but of
course
the agent is keeping track of all the
hypothesis
and so in this case can go and create a
new one and we can see a 12% hypothesis
and and so on and so forth, right? Of
course, we define the number of
iterations that we want to run.
Um of course, the way we create the
baseline data is, you know, we just run
the evals once and we generate basically
a document and this is super helpful
because it gives the coding agent the
information about the current status of
the system. Then this generates a
baseline report which contains, you
know, all these informations.
It contains what are the cases, it
contains summary, what's working, what's
not working.
So basically,
our coding agent it's going to have a
clear picture of what's happening right
now. And so, it will try to understand,
okay, how do I improve this system from
this moment?
And so, from now on, we can start with
the first iteration. So, every iteration
starts with a new branch. We create an
hypothesis.
Um the system changes the agent to
implement that hypothesis.
We run the evals. We run our eval suite.
And we generate a reports.md file, which
contains everything that happened after
we run the evals.
We update the memory file, uh which is
like a global memory file across all the
runs.
And if the metrics improved, then we
continue from this branch.
Um if the metrics didn't improve or we
have a strong regression or something
bad happened, uh then we roll back to
the previous branch.
Of course, um
the generated hypotheses are based on
what the agent reads when it starts the
investigation, which is the memory file,
uh the reports file, so it has access to
pretty much everything.
And that's what happens when we run
multiple iterations, right? So, let's
assume that in the first case, I create
a branch, I create an hypothesis, uh I
run the evals, everything goes well, so
I get an improvement, so I am fixing one
failure mode. Um therefore, I continue
from that branch. I create a new one so
that I can keep track of every change.
Um I create the new that new branch. I
try new hypothesis.
This time,
it didn't really improve, so maybe I get
a regression, maybe things didn't
improve really. Uh so, what I do is
I roll back to the previous branch, so
the first branch where we had a real
improvement in the system.
And then from here, I create a new
branch, and I try a new hypothesis, and
so on and so forth.
At the end, what we're building is a
full change log of all the changes we
have done,
um
every improvement in improvement or
regression as we can see here on the
right.
We are seeing all the hypothesis that we
are doing and of course, if we want
we can also see all the hypothesis
because every hypothesis is building a
report. So, let's assume that something
didn't really go
well in terms of evals. Maybe the evals
didn't improve after an hypothesis, but
maybe that hypothesis was promising,
right? Maybe the agent was onto
something, but it just didn't implement
the system
the change in a correct way, right? What
we can do is as humans,
we can just go back into the hypothesis,
read, understand what the agent was
trying to do, and then maybe steer it in
the right direction next time.
Of course,
this is the real task on a on a real
agent that we did have.
And as we can see here, the baseline
accuracy was 67%
um
but then in something around 10
iterations, we managed to reach 86%
in our evals without actually cheating
because it found edge cases, it improved
the system prompt, it improved the tool
descriptions to catch more edge cases,
and it also fixed some tools logic. So,
that's a real agent that is now running
in production
and actually this system found ways to
improve it more and more.
Now, the second class of problems that
we are going to tackle today is not the
evals data, but bad performances on live
data. By live data, we mean data that we
collected by our real users, beta
testers, subject matter experts, you
know, all the people that are actively
testing and using the system
and they're giving us a feedback. Just
as an example, you can see here on the
right, was this response helpful? And
you got yes or no, and then you get a
note. And basically, we leverage this
data to uh further optimize our agents.
Now, how do we do that? Uh this is the
full flow that we will see in details.
So, first of all, of course, we will
need our users to actually use the
system. Uh then, we collect all the
traces, right? So, we collect all the
informations from our users.
Our users can either give us a feedback
that we've just seen, so thumbs up,
thumbs down with the with the comment,
or
uh our subject matter experts can
annotate the trace. So, basically, they
can go on the platform that we are
using, they can look at the trace, look
at the input, look at the output, uh
look at basically like all the tools
that have been called, uh look at the
agent behavior,
and then annotate the trace by giving us
a feedback about how the agent performed
and how it should have performed.
Once we collect
a a a relatively good number of traces,
once we have um enough information, we
basically run an agent workflow that we
built.
So, basically, we analyze all the traces
with both the negative and positive
feedback, but we are more interested
about the negative feedback here. So, we
analyze all these traces. We do
clustering of the failure modes, right?
So, based on all the feedback that we
collected, we try to understand, okay,
given all this five feedback, what are
like the five, six, seven failure modes
that we have here?
And then, we analyze these um
we analyze these clusters of failure
modes with our subject matter experts.
So, we say, "Okay,
based on those 10 traces, we can note
that the agent in this specific case
performed poorly because of reason X,
for example."
We validate all this with our subject
matter experts.
And then we do have a fix proposal,
which gets generated and implemented by
our coding agent.
Then we implement this
and then we ship it to production to see
whether it actually improved on real
data. And of course, we use the traces
that we do have as regressions. So, we
test our fix against our traces first of
all.
But let's see that in detail.
So, first of all,
the user tests the system. So, in this
case, we have a very simple example,
"How can I optimize a React component?"
Here we have the answer. Here we have,
you know, the information about the
component, whatever, right?
So, that's the first step.
Second step is
we are going to collect all the tracing
information. So, we are collecting
everything from user interaction,
the tool usage, the how much time the AI
took to respond, you know, how many
tokens we burned, everything.
The second step then is
the user, once we collected the user
behavior, we do expect the user to give
us some feedback.
As I was mentioning, thumbs up, thumbs
down,
and then a a comment saying what went
well, what didn't,
and what's the expected behavior of the
system.
And then of course, the other option
that we were discussing is that the
actual subject matter experts can
annotate the trace. So, in case you
don't have a feedback from the real
user, I can ask the subject matter
experts to take a look at at trace,
invest their time, and give us feedback
as they were users. The third step is
now to collect all the traces with
feedback and download them locally in a
JSON or whatever format you're using. As
you can see here in this case, we have
114 traces, and we're using those traces
to then do the cluster analysis. How do
we run the analysis? Well, this is
actually a skill that we built.
Basically, the skill it's going to
instruct the coding agent properly to go
in the go in the JSON file, look at all
the traces, uh run some clustering, um
then we do an adversarial review of
that. So, basically, um once we have all
the clusters, we do also a little bit of
root cause analysis because, of course,
our coding agent has access to the
actual code of the AI agent, so it can
do some root cause analysis. It can try
to understand what happened, uh
especially because it has also access to
the details of every trace. So, it can
go within the trace, understand why the
agent answered that way,
you know, trace it down to the root
cause. Um
and then what's going to do is going to
um propose possible improvements. And
what we get at the end of this process
is a full markdown report, which is very
helpful for us. Uh it's going to give us
like the positive feedback, the negative
feedback, the negative rate, you know,
we are just trying to collect as many
data as possible.
And so, we get this very complete um
executive summary and this very complete
report, which tells us
what are like all the clusters which are
not working as the user was expected.
So, in this case, uh we have that we
have a small markdown formatting
failure, which is saying URLs are not
hyperlinked, and there are some
formatting inconsistencies.
So, it's linking some of the traces with
the trace ID.
Uh it's mentioning the user feedback.
It's showing like some root possible
root causes and it's telling us, "Okay,
how do we fix it?" Right? Once we have
this full report, our work is not done
yet because this report will contain all
the possible failure clusters reported
by users, but now what we have to do is
to triage everything and validate with
subject matter experts. Once we are
doing Once we do the triage and the
validation, then we prioritize and we
understand what we want to fix now, fix
later, don't fix.
Um and so, either we fix it with the
agent, so we give to the agent, you
know, all the context, we give it the
failure mode, we give it the traces, and
we ask our agent to fix it.
Or we discard it because sometimes it
can be the the failure cluster can be a
false positive or can be an intended
behavior or maybe
the user gave us
um a feedback which is not really useful
for us at this moment. So, you know,
there is a little bit of human judgment
here.
As I was mentioning earlier, all the
failure modes that we are founding
during this investigation step, they
will become part of the golden dataset
that we mentioned earlier and the eval
suite is updated to spot those
regressions. So, in case these failure
modes
for whatever reason is introduced uh
later on in the code, we will spot it
very fast because now it lives into our
golden dataset and our scorers.
In terms of how often the report gets
generated, it really depends on your use
case. Uh we found out that one per
sprint is good enough, but really
depends on how much data you have,
right? So, if you have 100 traces, it's
you might want to generate that at 100
traces, but if you have like 10,000
traces with feedback, might be too much,
so you might want to, you know, generate
multiple reports. So, it's really on
your use case. We found out that once
per sprint is actually reasonable.
Uh
in multiple use cases, what we found is
that a coding agent, when instructed, uh
has been able to fix an entire suite
of issues like the one that we have seen
earlier, uh with just one prompt. So,
once we give enough context and once we
give the coding agent the ability to uh
test its changes against some regression
tests, uh then everything becomes way,
way easier for the for the coding agent.
And then, uh in some complex cases, uh
we have paired this approach with
AutoAgent, uh and so we basically
pointed out AutoAgent to some of the
failure clusters, um and we let
AutoAgent build some draft PRs for us.
Now, of course, both AutoAgent and this
pipeline to improve um
agents based on live data, they're
possible thanks to Harness Engineering.
So, basically, the core idea is that we
are leveraging a set of things so that
our coding agent has a powerful enough
harness so that it can change the codes,
validate its own changes, which is like
super important, uh and then propose new
changes if the updates that it did
didn't lead to the
to the outcome that we were looking for,
right? So, just very, very quickly,
Harness Engineering is the idea of
building the environment around our
coding agent so that they can work
reliably. Uh so, we are giving all the
constraints, all all the tasks, the
feedback loop, we are giving the
governance to our um coding agents. And
we are doing that with a few things,
right? Which we've already mentioned.
The first one is spectrum environment.
So, for example, when we are trying to
fix some um failure modes, every failure
mode becomes a spec. Um we are creating
a spec for the expected behavior of the
agent, and then we are implementing
that.
Then we have quality gates uh like
linting uh our unit tests. We have our
our evals.
Um
we have LLM uh code review, so a bunch
of stuff. Uh everything related to
context engineering, so giving the right
context to our agent. And then, of
course, observability. Um because we
need to know what's happening, right? Um
if we don't know what's happening when
we ship in production, we are basically
blind, right? So, we want to ensure that
we know what's happening so that our
coding agent can fix any bugs or
anything once once it's found.
So, um I hope that this has been
interesting or helpful. I hope you're
going to implement some of those
techniques in your agents. And in case
you have any questions about this talk,
uh please feel free to reach out on
LinkedIn. I would love to have a chat
with other people which are building
agents. I know how hard it is. I know
how interesting it is. So, in case you
have like anything that you would like
to talk, uh I would love to get a
message on LinkedIn. So, I hope you
enjoyed this talk, and wish you a great
day. Cheers.